hi my name is marilee i'm seven years
old and today two chefs are going to
compete to make my dream dish
[Music]
hello
hi
i'm ellen i'm alvin there's a party of
elves behind us and i heard that this is
food for the elves is that true yes okay
hi my name is ellen bennett i used to
cook professionally and now i'm the
founder and ceo of hedley and bennett
i'm excited i wanna see what you're
going to do so what are these that
you're drawing right here they are
little tiny meatballs these are they're
hats
oh like santa hats i have no idea how to
make that happen what's your favorite
kind of food
lasagna oh i love lasagna that's so good
oh maybe some tacos because those are so
good right what is this green thing that
you're uh there's some sort of noodles
those are some interesting noodle shapes
you have there and i'm seeing some
smiley faces so they're happy noodles
yes and the noodles have faces on them
like what the heck i think the elves
will love this very much and they're
spying on us so you can go ask one
behind us did you ask the homeboy up
there on the left i think his name's
greg so greg oh you're sleeping
greg's sleeping these are little
colorful presents
do they have anything delicious inside
it's a surprise and then she throws in
these presents on top what am i going to
do with that
marley what are you drawing right now
what is that that's like some sort of
edible tinsel
edible tinsel
i got nervous there real quick okay is
that more tinsel more tinsel in a
different color this is getting
complicated it's gonna be fine
well merrily you drew a fantastic
drawing i think we both have a lot of
ideas what we want to cook for you so
we're going to get to work put our chef
aprons on and we're going to make you
something delicious okay yeah good job
see you soon
hi so how are you guys doing oh good
okay good
so here's my plan i'm going to start
with a bed of creamy tomato sauce topped
with tri-color pasta for her noodles for
her santa hat meatballs i'll be using
frozen meatballs with cherry tomatoes
and cream cheese for the presents i'm
going to be frying mozzarella and tying
it off with a chai bow and topping it
with a bow tie pasta all topped off with
edible chive and paprika tinsel so
here's what i'm thinking the happiest
holiday nacho snow globe for the base
i'm going to use refried beans and queso
on top for my noodley squiggles
butternut squash sweet potato bell
peppers and tortillas to make everything
happy i'm going to use kalamata olives
as smiley faces for the santa meatballs
i'm going to do chorizo meatballs and
add a tortilla chip on top as a hat the
presents will be an avocado box with a
surprise of guacamole inside on the top
for the ribbon i'm going to use thinly
sliced tomatoes and finally i'm going to
make piles of snow with sour cream and
cotija cheese on top
before we start any cooking i brought
you a very important tool what
your first heavily invented
yes that's from your apron line right
yes that's awesome yes wow let's tie it
in the front amazing so that you can
tuck a towel through
i feel like superman appreciate it
okay so with my apron on i'm gonna start
cooking the first thing i'm gonna do is
start with some fresh pasta so i have
some flour make a little hole it's
called a well i like egg yolks i think
it's gonna make the pasta really yellow
so i'm gonna go with six whole egg yolks
and then season some salt whisking the
egg yolks into a nice little paste i'm
making
the
squiggle
worms
for my secret experience what does that
mean
well my dish is not just a dish it's
going to be a whole world is it an
amusement park
maybe no
going up against ellen she is a
professional chef he knows what she's
doing she probably will blow me out of
the water so this is gonna be a pretty
tough time alvin's super sweet really
nice guy i'm gonna crush him he's just a
delightful young man who's about to get
slayed all right those look a little
drying and add a little bit of water i'm
going to slice
sweet potato i like to use a mandolin
because it makes it perfectly cut look
at that boom it's like so
perfect i'm gonna move on to my
butternut squash that is huge is that
from area 51
whoa look at that that's so satisfying
so wow that's fine you know pasta dough
it's a labor of love man we merely
appreciate this all right my pasta dough
is nice it's smooth it's great supple
i'm gonna wrap it up and make two more
look at this this is like the best
handle ever whoa it's so it's like
cantaloupe
look how pretty that is yeah so now i'm
moving on to my
tortilla shapes
really had all those fun squiggles that
she made and i want to recreate those so
i'm going to fry tortilla chips
and
bake butternut squash and sweet potato
oh squiggles like the picture so i look
over ellen's got a lot of stuff and i'm
a little intimidated because i'm just
needing my little dough ball and she's
already got like mountains of color next
to her alvin are we allowed to grab that
drawing so we can look at it
sure let's do it i'm gonna lay it here
just to get inspired oh yes i'm now
gonna throw my garlic in bell peppers
yellow and red touch of salt pepper a
little bit of lime juice a little bit of
apple cider vinegar i'm just tossing
them and i'm just going to do it lightly
because i want them to have shape
because i'm going to stab them into the
refried beans before so i'm going to
stab them in that's aggressive
i have my yellow pasta dough so i want
to work on my second one which is a
green one so
i'm gonna put in egg yolks again and
then i also have some spinach that is
cooked down drain hoping that this is
gonna give it a green color
this is looking really green i'm pretty
into it okay dry ingredients salt flour
give it a check and see
oh that's workable oh yeah that feels
nice let's do this bench flour so the
dough doesn't stick and then same thing
just going to knead this until
it becomes a nice soft supple dough it's
feeling really nice though it's super
fun to make fresh pasta so i feel like i
am in my lane so now i'm moving on to my
oven
land
more salt i'm gonna run off and take my
sweet potatoes and butternut squash
throw them in the oven
and i'll be right back will you take
care of my station while i'm gone i'll
do my best thank you promise thank you
promise okay i'll be right back
okay red pasta same thing
a lot of egg yolks
and to make it red i was thinking tomato
paste because it's really red does it
need more i'm gonna add some paprika to
make it more red that's pretty red okay
in with the flour okay that's like more
orange
next up i am
going to refried beans i just took one
garlic smashed it a little bit i'm
throwing in a little bit of onion and i
have just canned refried beans and i'm
just judging them refrying the refried
beef so try so like try fry and like
squared
yeah re-refresh
i'm gonna add some cheese i'm folding in
fontina cheese which melts so cleanly
it's like
glorious so as my abuelita would say i'm
adding a little bit caldo de pollo which
is just chicken
chicken stock or stew or soup
actually i really like the color of this
it's orange and it's kind of dark which
is great
so yeah i'm gonna wrap this up pasta
doughs are done and then i'm gonna move
on to something else so i'm using a cast
iron skillet and they're coming out a
little bit brown things happen you make
mistakes and it's okay you just have to
move on quickly so i'm not gonna let
this cast iron skillet get in my way i'm
just gonna change pans and keep on
rolling making little santa hats for my
happy meatballs these are just frozen
meatballs i reheated them i would have
made fresh ones except i think kids like
frozen meatballs to me i think frozen
meatballs taste great alvin's making
pasta from scratch but i just saw him
pull out frozen meatballs that's crazy
meatballs are easy it makes it that much
more delicious so i'm just saying you
could have made meatballs i'm like dude
frozen meatballs taste great
all right i'm gonna make a little
creamy cream mixture
with some cream cheese and heavy cream
to use as like the the white parts for
the santa hat all right new approach i
changed pans stainless steel it just
feels like the better move that cast
iron was getting really hot and was
starting to brown my tortillas
and i've got my back up in the oven
hopefully we can get some good chips out
of this all right i took my tortillas
out and now i'm just going to sprinkle
some
salt onto them quickly
so i got a piping bag here just planning
to pipe some festive cheer under these
santa hats with a tomato right there and
then put
a little bit on top that's kind of cute
that is one santa hat
okay this didn't turn out the way i
wanted it to that's fine
that might come to bite me later okay
i'm feeling more confident about my
tortilla chips now they're starting to
look nice and even
now i'm moving on to my meatballs i've
got the chorizo
onion
garlic a little bit of cotija cheese
bread crumbs some salt some pepper
cilantro and then i'm just gonna make
little balls
alvin how are you gonna do your gift uh
well
i think kids like cheese
and merrily did say that she wanted to
have like a surprise inside yes and i
thought that maybe i could make
mozzarella cubes the size of gifts but
like fried so that when you bite into it
it's like cheese inside kind of like a
mozzarella oh i like that i think this
technique is pretty smart
okay i have
a lot of cubes to choose from so i'm
going to bread them in flour eggs and
panko to go in order they look pretty
dope things are going pretty well all
right i'm going to make a really quick
guac a bunch of really delicious olive
oil
maldon salt and lots of
lime juice take my other avocado and i'm
gonna slice it with the mandolin so that
they're perfect sheets i'm going to
put lime juice all over it because i
don't want them to oxidize
seasoning with some
salt some kosher salt and then i'll cut
them
into little cubes
so my oil pretty hot keep me at 300 so i
can cook the cheese so
i'm gonna try to throw in a cube and
see if it works out then we'll do some
more oh we're frying
there we go i'm making quite literally a
glock
it's a box too precious
i think it's not gonna work i'm freaking
out a little bit because this does not
look pretty i'm not liking this avocado
box it's just not
holding its shape or its structure it
looks a little flimsy
oh those glock boxes my back-up plan
is
potatoes you know sometimes you just
have to uh decide that something didn't
work and move on i want to see if i can
tie a bow around it with a chive
so chives they're not as flexible as i
thought they were these gifts are really
giving us a run for our money what the
heck man why did i do this to myself i'm
thinking the same thing i am now making
the queso now i'm going to heat this
i'm going to add my half and half
with my fancy french cheese
and then i'm going to add the velveeta
monterey jack and the cheddar
have a little bows here one two three
that's cute yes okay i'm moving on to my
potatoes with conviction
they are my backup plan it is very
official they are now the potato gift
boxes we will not speak of the avocado
gift box
i don't even know what you're talking
about don't tell anybody zip it
these are definitely going to hold their
shape
mark my words the potatoes are in
they've been boiling for a little bit
they're going to come out i'm going to
cut them make them into perfect squares
throw them in the fryer so that's where
i'm at how are you doing i just trimmed
my tell me tell me where tell me how
you're doing
i'm doing pretty great my bow ties i
trimmed them off to make a nice little
bow shape and then i'm gonna finish off
my presents
[Applause]
i need to finish my potatoes i need to
conquer those
gift boxes
dough's been resting they're soft i'm
gonna cut them into chunks there's
something super satisfying about just
making
fresh pasta by yourself i'm feeling a
little more hopeful with my potato
squares so i'm taking the edges of the
bell pepper
that kind of looks like wow
these potato boxes are turning out
perfectly they're exactly what i wanted
they have structural integrity
and
they look awesome yes so in the drawing
i think they're kind of like these wider
thicker noodles not super long and kind
of have a funny like curve to them i
don't think any traditional kinds of
pasta would fit that so i'm just doing
it by hand it's okay if it's a little
wonky you know i think texture adds a
little flavor sometimes so that's true
dough number two the green one
this dough is so awesome to work with
very pretty
nice little golden brown guy i might
even throw in my guac box i might pull
in the eggs are you gonna do it are you
gonna do it really special you might do
it
this is the red ones the tomato paprika
pasta
so for my smiley faces i've got olives
and some
little tweezers that i'm going to use to
place the eyeballs like so
okay i think this is enough pasta for
one portion for merrily yellow green and
orange orange red i think it's gonna
taste great water's boiling
let's cook these noodles man cooking for
kids i know this is hard and it's really
exhausting i'm so tired i feel like we
need to take a nap what if we just like
lean into each other well okay
see you guys
i'm going to put the foundation i wanted
to
make some structure so hers is kind of
scattered so i'm going to take a similar
approach and the last thing i need to do
is to make the edible tinsel so i'm
going to chop up some chives oh my god
yours looks insane holy moly
all right last touch the green and red
tinsel i think a little bit of paprika
okay guac boxes
it worked
little cilantro palm trees oh oh my gosh
i almost forgot my potatoes not the
potatoes oh yeah the gift boxes
great i think i'm good i'm ready to show
this to her yeah are you ready yeah good
job
so i think that merly's probably going
to like this because of this wonderful
colorful
magical explosion of different shapes
textures heights along with her happy
faces little mounds of snow the palm
trees made out of cilantro
it's all there and it's a party overall
i'm pretty happy with the way the pasta
and the sauce taste i think the colors
are great i think the meatballs look
really cool i would say i did a pretty
good job at recreating how her dish
might look in real life so i really
think marilee is going to enjoy eating
this bring on my elf dinner
wow
i definitely see go little presents
and i guess lasers supposed to represent
grand noodles
and a little samson meatball from right
here
and this is a little happy face i am so
excited that she is spotting every
single little element no detail got past
her
whatever this is
it tastes easy
[Music]
tastes like a potato
that's good
it tastes like a cheesy meatball it's
sort of spicy a little but in a good way
spicy
and she likes it yes
it tastes like it has avocado in it and
i don't like avocado
all that time for the glock box and she
doesn't like avocado
out of everything on here i like a santa
meatballs best
i thought the potato presents were a
really good idea
i feel like i've got a good shot wow
where do i begin with this
it looks like spaghetti with a little
santas
and some presents and
colorful noodles i'm excited about this
we are off to a good start
it tastes like some sort of weed oh
these chives are gonna be then to me man
i don't know what it's inside the
presents
she takes another bite of the cheese
cube and she still doesn't know what it
is i thought kids love cheese
[Music]
tastes like a tomato i don't like
tomatoes
[Music]
it tastes like an ordinary meatball
really good
she says
it tastes ordinary i think i'm gonna
beat him in the meatball department
[Music]
i really like the noodle it's really
good
the finn i like the least is probably
whatever this is
she likes some stuff on mine she doesn't
like some stuff on ellen's i think we
both have a chance here
hi
hi hello all right so marilee you had
two dishes today which one did you like
better the nachos or the pasta i liked
ganachos yes
i'm so glad you like my dish it's over
to alvin but hey i got an apron that's a
win in my book because i like your dish
here i love it
yay thank you marilee it's beautiful i
won
woohoo
it feels awesome maybe i should just go
back to making giant food
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
you